[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time with matthew
mcconaughey sometimes oh no you're not
matthew mcconaughey yeah we don't have
him here for that part and i'm link this
week at the round table of dim lighting
we are
talking to matthew mcconaughey
the circle it is not an interview it's a
we wanted it to be a conversation we
wanted it to be an extension of what ear
biscuits has become even though
it is exceptional that we decided to do
an interview and we didn't do it just
because well he's so famous we got to
talk to him
it was that and i mean it was it was
more than that it was it was personal
for us honestly uh and we're not about
to make ear biscuits uh anything other
than what it is right uh for them for
the most part i mean
we kind of broke the seal on okay we can
bring in a guest sometimes but the
reason that we decided to do this is it
goes back to
i guess it was
beginning of 2020 is when we were
actually we were given
matthew's book green lights
which is something that happens pretty
often right celebrities write books and
they in their their teams send them out
to other celebrities or people who have
an audience so they might read them and
talk about them it's we so we end up
getting quite a few books
and i saw
this you know
his book come in and i was like oh this
is this is interesting this is more of
like a memoir
kind of thing
um but i didn't immediately like say
okay i'm going to start reading this
thing it was my good friends lance and
lacey you know of beard and lady who who
make all the grooming products from
mythical oh really who they live a life
of
adventure and they live a life of
embracing
new ideas and new challenges and
following those things
for instance
with gusto deciding to revitalize a
historic haunted hotel in arkansas and
turn it into
a hotel that you can visit
that's like the latest thing that
they've done they're always doing
something like that i mean we wouldn't
have our grooming products if it wasn't
for for for them hatching that out yeah
yeah and so when they said have you
listened to green lights yet and we like
jesse and i have a text thread with them
that is
very much that have you have you watched
this thing i told you when we went home
for christmas
uh or whatever it was for the summer
they had the they were like you gotta
watch this and you gotta yeah
i waited specifically to watch that with
them but anyway so the recommendation
coming from them was like all right i'll
do it yeah and so did you read it or
listen i listened to it because i've
kind of moved almost exclusively into
audiobooks to my
uh not there's a not a small amount of
shame that comes with that uh just for
me personally because i have this bias
towards reading
but i can do anything else while i'm
listening so i just end up listening to
all kinds of books like multiple books a
month is like my pace now right so and
then you started talking to me about
aspects of it
like
just
how his approach to being expressing
himself and being creative and going
after his music well in 90 and the
princess
to begin with was
ma'am you can't believe this thing that
happened to matthew right right just a
great choice and you can't believe the
way that matthew mcconaughey decides to
tell you the story you can i mean
everybody knows matthew mcconaughey at
this point so you can imagine how he's
going to tell this story but so
listening to him do it in his very
mcconaughey way it's just it was a treat
and now i was resisting telling you the
story you know when you get into
something you want to just tell people
the stories and you're like mr spoiler
reverse to the nth degree so i have to
be like well there's a story about him
going up australia and it's like okay
well i've been australia you can't you
know you can't give away too much but
then uh you ended up getting into it he
went as a foreign exchange student you
should say that but yeah um i didn't
listen to it for a number of weeks
because i had other stuff but then i had
hit this dry spell and i was like i need
something
and i started listening to it uh two
weeks ago
or
and and then after i was almost done
with it is when they were like hey he
wants to come on your show we're like
i think we got to make this happen
because we we just it resonated with us
so much so
as you'll see we uh
we turned it into
us getting what we needed out of it and
our own purposes yeah it's not really an
interview as you can i would advise most
most interviewers to not begin
interviews by just telling stories about
themselves like we did it was kind of
like what chris farley used to do on snl
when he was remember that time when you
no we didn't do that no but uh i had a
feeling not knowing matthew personally
but knowing of him and in listening to
the book and i had a feeling that he
would just get right into the he's he's
a let's let's have a campfire
conversation kind of guy
uh and so he just he stepped right in
here and uh it would have been nice to
have him actually at the at the table
but you know what
he's still on video chat it is what it
is video version it's there
all right let's get to it but first we
always want to encourage you to go to
mythical.com to rep your boys do you
have any clue what's over there if you
haven't been over there there's a lot in
a couple of weeks it's going to be new
stuff so
go to mythical.com browse it you don't
have to make any commitments and if
you've gotten yourself purchasing
something then thank you and if you want
something uh
things come and things go there's
actually the last chance section where
things that will go away and never come
back we've put that all together in one
nice little section for you so you won't
complain about not being able to get
something the last chance section
mythical.com
[Music]
it's great to meet you we don't
typically have guests on our podcast but
we both
read and listen to green lights and we
love good stories
and you got some good stories man
and uh
it's been it's been many moons since we
have had a conversation outside of just
the two of us talking because we figured
out we've got quite a bit that we can
just talk about to each other about yeah
um
but we both
connected with your book and i mean you
know lots of people have connected with
your book in in in a big way
but something about your stage of life
uh your story kind of you're you're
you're coming from small town south
there's just there was a lot that we
could relate to
uh and there's a lot that's on our minds
that i think selfishly
you know when you start talking about
legacy
in green lights
yeah i mean that that's like we're
having so many conversations about that
and also on this podcast so i think
selfishly we just want to pick your
brain a little bit and kind of unpack
some more of that but first when it
comes to these stories
uh and just relating to that there's
there's a couple of uncanny
yeah uncanny parallels i love you
talking about your mom basically telling
you to plagiarize the poem
that then
i won and then you won
i won the whatever the seventh grade
poetry contest yeah because i mean talk
about yeah
because if does the poem mean something
to you
yeah i understand it i mean so you like
it yeah i mean it it it brings up a
feeling in you method yeah i mean it
says if all that i would want to do
would be to sit and talk to you would
you listen i mean that's like yeah you
know mom
so you understand that yeah then write
that
well but it's it's ann ashbury
no but as i said you sign your name
because you understand it it means
something to you so it's yours
if it means something to you it's yours
now here's my version of my mom we had
this uh
poster contest
county-wide county-wide harnett county
anti-drug
uh message and i told my mom now my mom
worked at the public health department
and there was a pamphlet for everything
and so she would come i mean that's how
i learned about sex through a pamphlet
she brought home a pamphlet she said
well
link this is here's an anti-drug one and
look there's a picture right here and it
says there are there are lots of fun
things to do instead of drugs
and then it's a guy holding all these
other things like
badminton thing and a like a an art and
art easel and stuff like that
and so she basically said
draw that
and but here's the thing about my mom
she
i don't even think she knew what
plagiarism was she didn't there was no
there was no process there was she
explained it to make it okay she didn't
have a pithy tenet that you can
prescribe
in your book you know for her it was
just very innocent this is a great idea
why don't you just do exactly that and i
did it and i won i mean he would buy a
long shot you won i won baby i mean he
won the whole county which i believed it
and i listen as his best friend at the
time
what grade was that five fourth or fifth
i had no idea i didn't tell anything i i
thought you would didn't ask you dug
really deep yeah deeper than ever
i still have it i have a laminated
poster of this in my office
that somebody mailed me
yeah and now the other thing that was a
bit of an uncanny parallel so
um
my dad is a bit of a larger than life
character
at any time throughout my life even when
i felt like i was afraid of nothing i've
always been afraid of him right right
and
in a good way the good fear
and i and so
by the time that we were
you know seniors in high school
in in in bowie's creek north carolina
where nobody had nobody that we knew had
taken any sort of entertainment path our
idea of being an entertainer was the guy
who would come to the middle school
dances
and do he was either a dj or he could be
a magician you know
yeah that was the guy right i've seen
him do both at once and um
so but we had this idea we want to go to
film school and
i had that conversation with my dad
that you had with your dad when you when
you caught when you called him up and
said i'm thinking about going to film
school and that was pretty built up for
you
you know
you kind of had to like breathe into
that moment right
very much so i mean
it was a moment where i wasn't sleeping
well with the idea of going to film to
law school so that was keeping me up at
night it was then it was weeks of
sharing stories and stuff i'd written
with my buddy rob bindler who was nyu
who was the only
film guy i knew
adam and plus he was at longview texas
he didn't watch many films there either
so i'm sending him stuff in new york
he's writing back going man this is
pretty good this is good and i knew he'd
give me an honest opinion and then i get
the confidence then i find the book
greatest salesman in the world the
agmandino book and you know sometimes a
piece of art or a book will find you or
a person will share something with you
and you're like
they've been reading my mail this is
direct line this was written for me
right now i have no question about it
when we have that clarity whether it's
true or not it is true right so that
book found me gave me the courage to say
that's what i'm doing and then i had to
plan out when the best time to call dad
was since he was paying tuition so i
said like i said in the book i picked
that tuesday night
seven o'clock he's home from work he's
already eating dinner he's having a beer
with mom on the couch best time to get
it yeah not monday tuesday
night and called him 7 36 and laid it on
him and
he gave me that great response you know
okay
more than yes he's don't half-ass it you
know but
go on about your story about so well
coming out of north carolina well the
thing is is that i must have not i did
not plan as well as you did because when
i told my dad dad
i'm thinking about going
you know lincoln and i are thinking
about going to film school right i mean
it had been years since we had done the
blood oath and said we're going to
create something together and like we
had really colluded and we had each
other and we like
you know worked up each other's ways we
had this plan at one point it was okay
uh
we're i'm we're going to go to unc
asheville i'm going to play basketball
but they have a film program and you're
going to be like and if you just want to
keep score i've done that that didn't
really come to fruition but then it was
just like okay are you going to do what
everybody else is doing and kind of just
going to the state school or whatever
and i said dad i i want to go to film
school
he didn't say don't half-ass it he said
well i'm not paying for that
but but the funny thing is is so and we
put that in in our our book uh the book
of mythicality we wrote a few years ago
by the way matt emman uh also our editor
incredible guy
uh oh yes matthew yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh inman enmity
yes
yeah what great hair you wait i cannot
quit complimenting on his hair oh my god
yeah well he's got great hair and we
actually like we experienced the
transition of his hair that's true
because in book one he i like to think
we inspired it it was it was closed
cropped but book two he you know it was
a new whole new thing um
so but in my because i put that in the
book and my dad said you know that's not
what i said that's you remember that
incorrectly
he
he said well i must have said something
that that was what you felt yeah yeah
and that was the result
he and my mom may know each other
i could see into it that he did not he
was not very supportive of that idea you
know i mean so we went to engineering
school and the rest is history and it
kind of worked itself out we took a more
a circle
y'all both could you both went together
yeah off the same school engineering
school and you end back up here sitting
next to each other having your platform
a form of
entertainment film storytelling here in
front of the mic yeah so it ended up you
know we found out what would have
happened we found a way it was quite a
circuitous path but i think it it turned
out to be the
the most strategic way for us to get to
where we wanted to get we just didn't
know that so i hear you he he did us a
favor
yeah you look it's all science looking
back
yesterday going forward but you can
connect all the dots whatever your dad
said or didn't say whatever you felt was
that ain't happening so derail and i'm
going my own way and you end up right
back and you go damn what if he would
have said yeah i go to film school
probably wouldn't work
exactly yeah well one of the one of the
things that uh we really connected with
and something that's kind of been on our
minds it relates to your sort of
your very
intentional decision that you made
to say
i'm not going to work on another rom-com
right yeah yeah yeah so talk a little
just for for anybody who
isn't familiar with that decision kind
of give some context for that decision
and then as it relates to your your
legacy is kind of where we want to take
sure sure um i think it's around two
thousand
ten-ish or so maybe a little earlier but
i'm rolling in rom-coms i've just done
had like four in a row
that have all done well
their bromcoms are middle budget studio
pictures meaning at that time has run 35
million dollar budgets
it's above the line cost because you
don't have a huge production value it's
not you're not like making a chris nolan
film where you're spending all this
money on production and
it's about how the two
you know when you most rom-coms how the
guy and the girl get along it's what the
chemistry of them them is and we know
they're going to meet them me at the
beginning break up for some reason in
the middle and then he'll chase her at
the end and catch her on a bridge or a
moped or something and the credits will
roll we'll be happy we got there then
the fairy tale is good we've seen it all
we know it's going to end but we just
want to see it again because
who are the who are the leads usually in
it do we do we want to follow them in
this love story yeah so i've done four
of these they're i'm the rom-com guy in
hollywood man i took the baton from hugh
grant and i'm running with it that's my
lane i'm i've got ownership of that lane
um i'm the go-to guy i like doing them
they're fun i call them saturday
afternoon characters so like a flip-flop
character you don't take rom-com you
don't get in there and hang your hat on
humanity
no it's you're supposed to bounce from
cloud to cloud and keep them light and i
believe i did a decent job of that
anyway with their success
they became so successful that the
dramas i did want to do
uh where i did want to hang my hat on
humanity and see if i could really flex
my active muscles the studio system said
no way mcconaughey no thank you and i'll
say wait i'll take a fidget ship pay cut
no thank you 100 pay cut no look man
i'll do it for
scale no we don't want you you stay
you're the rom-com guy stay over there
oh damn it well that coincides with the
fact that i've now met the woman who
later became my wife but i knew i was
fell in love with her very quickly
camilla
and we had uh we we we
had our first child she had the child we
made the child right so i have first
child coming to town if you know from
the book my life's dream was to be a dad
and so
i'm like all of a sudden my life is full
and vital i
my i get
madder i get sadder i laugh louder i
have more joy i mean i gotta go by
meaning i got meaning in my life right
my life is now not bouncing cloud to
cloud like a rom-com all right so i'm
going hey
well i wish my work could challenge the
vitality of my life
but it doesn't ah damn it so
if i can't do what i want to do i'm
gonna quit doing what i've been doing
so i said no to rom-coms made the call
to my money man to my agent stuff and i
said i'm not gonna do any more rom-coms
can you be a keeper at the gate and hold
him back from coming my way
um she had many a tear with camilla
because this drought could be i could i
may not work for i don't know how long i
may not ever work again in hollywood
if i stick to this which when i was
gonna do it i knew it was gonna stick to
it so um
six months go by i'm offered nothing but
rom-coms
no thank you no thank you no thank you
no thank you i think a really fun story
just as i'm going on my preacher's box
now and you sound like and i sound so
puritanical i think it's a really nice
story to tell you that at month eight
without working there was a rom-com that
came in with a 5 million offer and i
read it i said no
they came back with an 8 million offer i
said no thank you they came back with a
12.5 million offer i said no thank you
they came back with a 14.5 million offer
i said let me read that thing again
how did it sound at that point
it was better it was funnier the thing
was more it was the exact same words as
the original offer but it was a better
script oh yeah it was so i ended up
saying no
i said no to that and that
i believe in hindsight was a bit of a
turning point meaning
in hollywood that's when i think the
studios that were had me on a list to
offer me movies that's when they got the
message oh mcconaughey is not bluffing
yeah he's serious he just turned it down
for 14.5 and it's a damn good script but
he's not doing it so i say no to that
then nothing comes in for um
another year
yeah and you know what
and and so and we know where it goes and
i do want to get into that but like even
pausing at this point i mean it's
i think we relate i mean our
our situation is different we're we're
in a different world of entertainment
but we have these ass but we have these
aspirations of being filmmakers and then
with the advent of youtube
we
you know that was our opportunity
to to develop our audience and
i mean we tried a lot of things before
landing on our daily show good mythical
morning which then became this thing
that
was a huge success so now 10 years
running
five days a week we've been we've been
putting out a couple videos a day
for our show really connecting with our
audience really i mean it's super
rewarding
so much of our career has come from the
opportunities that that show that we
created and continued to evolve
afforded us
right but
and now we're sitting here
44 43 years old
continuing to to invest and build a team
around this show
yeah um also doing this podcast which is
is
is a passion project of ours which is
doing really great too but there's this
itch especially i feel like at this
point in our lives
um
you know i've got three kids rhett's got
two kids we've got uh happily married
you're like
we we're living the dream
that we that we
we shook with a blood oath
in middle school and no matter what
rhett's dad said or implied
we found a way
to make it happen
and now we're sitting here and we've got
a lot of gas in the tank
yeah
you've built currency
so i feel like
you know i don't want to build it up as
a turning point or but i do
maybe it is i you know these are the
things that we're wrestling with well we
start asking the questions in terms of
legacy is gmmm our
rom-com right cause it's it's the thing
that it it works it there's great
there's great money in it it's the thing
we're known for
uh it's it's just uh and you you talk a
little bit about the the fear you know
sort of
you can make fear
motivated decisions but you kind of had
to you had to push that you said earlier
you said good fear the way you feared
your dad you had a good fear the i mean
yeah man well one congratulations you
guys are mid-40s i'm 51 i mean what do
we call this
term midlife cri well whatever yeah yeah
we got the at least we got the hoots
ball to lean into some resistance yeah
okay at least we got some food spot to
question a blind spot to question
oh am i moving can i i'm successful
am i what i'm doing is it significant
there's a difference uh hey also we
don't want to boohoo
our rom-coms right you know what i mean
definitely like i trust me i remember i
i was
when i when i was trying to make that
choice and i was still doing the
rom-coms i remember talking to my great
mentor penny allen i was like i just she
was like what is bugging you about i go
i just feel like i'm like i'm like i
feel like i'm just an entertainer she
goes
who the hell do you think you are
sloughing off being an entertainer
what you got against being just an
entertainer i was like thank you
put me in my place you know so we have
to give the credence i think to what
we've done and not try to make a
straight line crooked
at the same time we want to lean into
well wait a minute man
is there is there more here can and can
it still be fun can we still have enjoy
because it doesn't have to i know what i
have to watch is
when things are going i love to work
hard
if my work's constructive and i feel it
working i don't mind if i can break a
sweat every day that's fun to me i don't
like to work hard and then be
frustrating go i don't know where it
went
but
i mean we don't we
i
i have to watch that if it's not hard i
don't think it's worthy
and sometimes my easiest stuff you know
when you sit there and you tell a joke
and you malaprop the damn thing and
people laugh at the male prop more than
they did at the real joke you're like oh
geez that was just an accident that was
the hit yeah you know we go we go out
you know and we we go i write the book i
got things in the book i'm like this is
going to be the home run man this time
some of the stuff that people never talk
about that it's this other stuff and i'm
like going oh you know so
i i look for it sometimes to be harder
than it should i have to balance that so
how do you lean into the blind spots but
also not just
like i said don't not trying to make a
straight line crooked not trying to go
well it's not hard enough this is worked
out
do we have we have to check in with
ourselves we come from
small towns in the south i dealt with
that okay my success early like geez why
me
i deserve this
you know what i mean
am i breaking a sweat enough you know
what i mean it's so
i i mean congratulations on the
questions guys yeah and i think i met
him too in my life
well thanks for the congratulations we
appreciate that and i mean we do we are
extremely grateful for what we've got
and the show is our friendship on
display and we can we can sit down and
behind our desk and we can just kind of
be ourselves and people are drawn to it
and we've got great relationships with
our fans because of it and it allows us
to launch other things that we want to
do to a certain level
but then you think about the stories
that we want to tell and the the
filmmakers that that we want to become
and there's a bit of a chip on our
shoulder you know you got gratitude on
one and then i think there's a chip on
the other one that's like okay you guys
came up from youtube
and maybe there's a little bit of
parallel to
sending the when you sent the business
sent the message to the business
that you weren't even gonna take
the 14.5 million dollar offer and that
really did it it's like
we're trying to find a way to say not to
our fans because they know but to the
gatekeepers to say
hey we're writing this thing and this
thing and we want we got to get it into
the right person's hands or we got to
we still have things we want to say and
assert ourselves
and it's it's different than what we're
known for and what we're successful for
right and it's so there's this
you know there's
it's it's a bit frustrating
it's also frustrating part because
you're not sure you're not sure
yeah go ahead because
you've already got in fact you're
sitting here we have microphones in
front of us i'm on your show you've got
a you you can be heard
right
even if you want to talk to even if
you're talking to those people out there
that may be able to say yes let me see
what you got your script want to maybe
finance that
you've got you've got you've already got
a huge leg up
so you're in
yeah
i mean
you know i mean
two things came to mind when you when
you were talking there is and this comes
when we're not sure and being not sure
is obviously very healthy and true for
us to to to be maybe sometimes more but
when it's time to take action
you can't i know you you all know you
can't be waiting for permission
oh yeah yeah yeah you know
you're gonna say
a version of effort this is what we're
doing
by hooker by cooking and we're not
asking permission and then it's going to
be i mean probably that i love there's a
line that that i
heard somewhere along my line in life
that i bring up in the book that
sometimes it's not about what she says
you make it's just about making damn one
and jumping and doing it and you find
out yeah like [ __ ] or get off the pot
kind of thing i mean go [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
it find out yeah you know i mean we we
it's our relationship for me i know a
lot of times it's my relationship with
time
we you know you get a decision like this
you start thinking ah man i don't know
if i am i wasting time do i have enough
time yeah and all of a sudden you look
up and you're 50 and you're going well
and then you're 55 then you're 60.
you're sitting like yeah why would it
when we were 46 why did we just go
let's see and plus and then what do we
find out oh time is actually on our side
but if with if we
head into it without complacency you
know what i mean i mean
what
it's just it's another version of your
stories you may maybe i don't know not
that you're asking my advice on this but
you've got to show are you pitching some
of these stories yeah yeah so i think
the way we're playing it right now is
you know really all along the the way
over the past 10 years since we've since
we've been in in la
we've been the business has been built
around what we've been doing on online
and that's where we built our team and
our studio and that's all working really
well in the meantime we've been like you
know we've been writing pilots we've
been writing features
we we are we're doing that and we are
getting in the rooms and you know it's a
completely different process
over here on the internet it's like idea
put together the team execute it see
what they think about it see what the
audience thinks about it there's no
gatekeeper when we get into the
traditional hollywood thing we kind of
deal with
the gatekeepers of it all right so i
think we're kind of in a let's have our
cake and eat it too
sure but when we like we both connected
with that story when you were basically
like
well i'm gonna and the dynamics are
different of course but you really i'm
gonna just turn the faucet off
right and they're going to be like the
only way you get this back on is if i'm
doing what i want to do specifically
right right and so that's kind of the
thing that's sort of ruminating right
now is like what you know what is that
what does that mean for us is that
because it's not like hey we're going to
stop doing the show that's the only way
for us to move to the next thing right
it isn't as clean as that for us but but
i think that the question you know
bringing it back to the idea of legacy
and what you're known for yeah
i think that's a part of it for us it's
just like okay if i'm walking down the
street if somebody recognizes me it's
gonna be like nine times out of ten it's
gonna be from good mythical morning and
it's gonna be oh the episode where you
guys ate the
uh you know the pig testicles
or whatever you know and it's just like
okay that's awesome i'm glad that meant
something to you
do i want the thing that nine out of 10
people remember me for is eating pig
testicles on the internet or do i want
to be like hey here's the thing here's
the thing that i want to there's a story
that i want to tell so what part of that
for you was like okay i mean
you know well i yeah i hear you i mean i
hear you look
you know
our favorite bands
still play their hits
the concert
yeah
you got a pretty good hunch
coming up in the encore yep
yeah i mean with good reason
yeah
i understand also i i'm still introduced
to the first three words i ever said on
film 1992 and days confused all right
all right all right yeah right
now
were there times in my life i'm like
really again
yeah
i look back and i go geez i'm glad you
didn't get get too upset about that
because you'd have been dorking out
mcconaughey are you kidding me and i
switched over to going you damn right
i'm the author of that and let me unpack
what that means to me and it was the
beginning of my career and it's three
affirmations and you're right puts a
smile on my face too hey i'll ride the i
what do you what do you mean am i tired
of it i wrote it
right it's about you know what i mean i
love you so
so so grabbing a hold of the greatest
hit and going you damn right and i
understand why it
became the greatest hit now
do you go
because does the success of what we're
understood to do and our brand is
can it
be so successful that it holds thing
other other avenues down for how it can
be heard and seen yeah yeah i remember
this eric church
i think he's north carolina didn't he
uh i is he
i'm not i think he might be yeah
anyway he
he came and played uh um uh
or one of our annual um fundraiser mjn m
event me mac brown who's coach at north
carolina and jack ingram he came and
played
and he wouldn't play any of his hits he
wasn't on purpose
on purpose i believe i didn't talk to
him long about it but i believe it was
about no he's in constant
creation yeah
fast forward before you get hooked into
that if i i think i believe his thought
was
oh if you're if i'm if i keep giving you
that you're anticipating that at the end
of the end of the night and you're not
going to be listening to mine he was
playing his new stuff stuff that
wasn't even hurt people didn't even know
i was like i suppose
yeah
you know what i mean but there's another
way to look at it um
i mean
how do you don't again you don't want to
boo-hoo
the rom-com yours you don't want to
boo-hoo the all-right all right right
you don't want to boo-hoo the success of
the show don't shoot that's what i mean
by don't make a straight line crooked
right like own that [ __ ] damn right you
know what i mean but
i hear you do you feel like you're being
held down i can't get this other thing
out that i think is as good or better
because it can only be seen through the
lens of
what i'd succeeded with before
yeah uh
i hear you you know what again i'm gonna
go back to that don't ask permission
yeah i like this permission to go
forward
and
you also we have to watch this with
legacy thoughts though man
if we are pre if we are solely based off
of projecting how we want to be seen
yeah we're not being subjective and
selfish enough
you know what i mean like we can be we
can be overly objective the idea of
legacy to you know to project into our
end go to our deathbed look back and ask
ourselves what's our eulogy going to be
what are we going to remember for i
think it's an extremely great thing to
do for ourselves but we can't live by it
or if we live by it
we're we're we're going to miss out
we're going to look up if we live to be
100 and go what'd you do the last 50.
you were trying to just get here living
off of what you what you thought the the
rolling credits were going to be yeah
you know well that's my that's
you know uh i don't know if you know
much about the enneagram personality
stuff but i'm i'm enneagram 3 which is
an achiever performer you know
and
one of the things that you do is you
over identify with what you've projected
out into the world
so whatever it is that you begin seeing
people respond to
yeah so if that was oh well let's i'm
going to be good at basketball okay that
well that's all right that's the thing
i'm going to be the basketball guy so oh
no i'm going to be the guy the guy who
plays music i'm going to be the guy who
makes youtube videos whatever the the
the arena was you yeah and so yeah
that's been that's what my therapy has
been about over the past few years is
learning to find well what's the
what does rhett actually
want and i and i do think i've gotten to
a place where it's less about
how do you want to be perceived and more
what how do you want to live your life i
mean that's the one of the things i
really admire about your philosophy of
life is it's it's about a a life well
lived it's about living life to the
fullest right um
and and i think that this kind of this
gets into another thing that i think
that as a
as a good southern boy you can also
relate to and that is the idea of
pairing
a desire for legacy with
humility
uh you know
you talk about uh
how to your family you're just matthew
right they immediately ground you the
same exact thing happens
my mom will just approach
people randomly in walmart and say do
you know rhett and link well that's my
son she will do that but when i'm with
her i'm just
i'm just rhett
and
uh there in the south there's this ethos
of
the moment that you're too big for your
britches everybody's going to let you
know right so how how have you kind of
paired that
the idea of legacy or being an
entertainer in general is like you got
something to say writing a book like
green lights you've got something to say
that you think is is worth people's time
how do you balance that with the concept
of humility
well it's a great question because
i don't know about y'all but the the
idea in the church that i was raised in
humility to be humble
to
bow
down
to make yourself at least number two
i i i
i could understand it
and get great worth out of it when i was
bending my knee
to my
god
but when it came to
society
mortal men women
i found that
i didn't know how to be humble
without losing confidence
and i found that when i would be humble
it was almost uh i didn't know how to be
humble you know those people that are
falsely modest and you're like you
condescending son of a [ __ ] cut that
out yeah you know what i mean cut that
out that's bs you're bs and not only me
but yourself uh you know what i mean
it's like no it's that
renise sherman story i tell hey she told
me you know what you're you're cute
you're really a cute young man when i
was in ninth grade i was like oh
she was like hey reached out and grabbed
my hammock she was a very good friend i
grabbed my hand and said what she goes
someone gives you a compliment it's true
just look them in the eye and say thank
you
yeah
what
yes ma'am heard now
i came across
um
a definition and this i find this very
true for me in my life all the time a
lot of times it's about what webster's
dictionary are we working off of
the the definition of humility because
i've questioned well you want me to be
humble
everyone says be humble but no one likes
to be humiliated
you know what i mean
right but yet humiliation is an
extension of being humble but no you ask
him you want to be humiliated everyone's
like no but you're going to be humble
yes please right so when i heard this
definition of humility
as being
knowing you have more
to learn
i was like oh
that's the way that's the one i'm
talking about i can i can go forward and
bow and have reverence and say please
and say thank you and respect
but i don't lose confidence
my shoulders didn't my shoulders could
still be back my head can still be high
my heart can be high if i because i
could admit that yes i've got more to
learn hundred percent i i purchase i'm
in
forever
different definition and it made it
click for me um which allowed me to be
allows me to be humble but still not
lose my confidence
because we know man confidence is a huge
thing and i'm a believer in our knit our
the necessity
of our ego
we try to pound that down if you don't
have an ego if you don't have judgment
you got no
identity you got to have it we got to
have a healthy ego we are everything
experience of our life no matter how
zen or or or selfless we are it comes
through us
it's the only feeling we can own
and it's ours and it's original
and we need to
put when that needs to be in capital
letters or in bold print to ourselves i
think it's a very
true thing to face that and look in the
mirror and go that's exactly what that
is i know you know i i have an opinion
there i know why i succeeded i know why
i had my hand in getting what i wanted
there i know why i had a hand in failing
to get what i wanted what it was what
you get whether it's winning or losing
well it sounds like you're you're
talking about the
it's really a form of realism right and
just being like
believing the truth about yourself right
if if that is well i am good at this
thing
right that's true
uh i need to work on this that's also
true so like more more of a
self-awareness
uh where you can kind of get find
yourself because i mean we we've all got
the imposter syndrome constantly any it
would show up in a new place a new room
a new project whatever you get that um
that impostor syndrome but then at the
same time i usually have two
equally
you know equal thoughts in my brain one
is i shouldn't be here and damn it i
should be here
[Laughter]
you know
uh and it's and it's sometimes i could
be a little bit yeah the false humility
stuff can be
uh problematic but the moment that that
you start to think that okay i've got
something to say that is
better or
uh my story's better than your story
kind of thing and and
and it becomes this thing where i am
belittling or taking advantage of others
in order to get my thing across yep
that's how it falls apart but
because i think i was trying to figure
out like when you talked about making
the selfish choice i think this helps
contextualize that
because because you did refer to
making the selfish choice
but i think there's caveats to it right
sure and it looks selfish is another
word that yeah my pastor says i'm
pushing a big rock up at steep
as you just said if it's belittling
others
i don't think it's true selfishness
in the infinite game in the law if we're
really playing the long game
for really trying to create green lights
in our life
live a full life a quality life
there are sacrifices we make today
to get a larger reward tomorrow and
someone would say well wait that's
sacrificing that what you want today
right now
that's that's
that's very unselfish of you say no
that's it that's very selfish of me
because i'm going to go without this
dime today to get my dollar next week
so if i have any time understanding
delayed gratification and quality of
life
and i'm considering hey damn i don't
want to fill my bank account
if i consider also i want to fill my
soul can i feel my souls account along
as well in the way i feel my bank
account
i would say that's being more selfish
because what's more selfish to get to
the end of your life and go i just
filled my bank account but my soul's
account was barren
screwed people over burned bridges did
what i wanted all the way down the road
and now i'm here a lonely sob i got no
family i burn i got broke things out
there gosh i would say that's less
selfish
yeah right because what got what got the
bigger roi
so
it's not in belittling others it's it's
it's because i'm with you if it starts
to be
at the expense of helping someone else
out
if that be if that which is the
historical sort of definition of selfish
um
doing things for one on one's own
without uh uh relation or or or empathy
for any anyone else it could be a
certain definition that's not what i'm
talking about right i'm actually trying
to say that the more selfless you are
the more selfish you are being
right religion says that i would also
say the more selfish you are being the
more selfless you may actually be being
as well i mean even that they're not an
end goal even the end goal of uh every
major world religion is is that ultimate
personal connection with the creator or
eternity in paradise i mean that's kind
of a selfish proposition
it's the most selfish proposition yeah
even if you're saying
well you're telling me i can live a
certain way and
you know let's get to heaven
right if you're living now that's that's
the ultimate selfish ambition whether
you're you know if for a believer who
prescribes to that i mean i think it's
we have to be in that version i would
say we have to be more selfish but now i
mind you i'm redefined i'm redefining
what that means the long game the long
term of selfishness if you're
prioritizing yourself and your own
health uh
you know you're everyone around you is
going to benefit i think is ultimately
bingo and you're taking trust in
yourself that's how you trust other
people respecting yourself that's how
you're going to respect other people
more and again these are just things
that we make a contradiction
which i don't believe are i believe much
more paradox
and
i think it it comes to light
specifically i mean when you were
talking about that juncture the
non-rom-com anymore juncture
and it wasn't just you making a decision
you said there were there were a lot of
tears and conversations with camilla and
you know you were you were starting a
family together and it was a palpable
risk
so and yeah and so it wasn't just
something that you're like i i want to
do what i want to do it i mean so you
were
you were taking into account your
your family and and and they had to be
on board
yeah and now
you know
my wife
understood she saw my pain and angst and
unrest
at wanting to
do
roles and have work that challenged the
vitality of my life she soon she
heard that coming from in here i mean
she was on board with me so then she
started squeeze out there and she goes
she's at one point this is gonna be hard
you don't know how long it's gonna be
you're gonna be dry how long you're not
gonna work
yeah she also knows well enough to go at
that time going
you not working who i know how much
significance you get from work
how much significance you get matthew
from accomplishing things
how how much you like to prepare then
finish then ah okay i did that i do i do
still do and she was like
boy every day you're saying every day
could be a saturday
without the structure of work
the two jobs a year three jobs a year
that you take that go for four months or
so so that could be appealing but that
could be scary
scary is all get out and i've said it
before you know
the days are long all of a sudden
i mean i can only attend the damn garden
and take you know be a good dad to my
son for so long all of a sudden about
three three o'clock i'm getting antsy
going i got nothing i'm building here no
calls are coming in start to look up
over there and go hey look at that
bottle hey might be tight well no it's a
little bit early on that okay
you know you get you get restless and to
hold a bearing there um
luckily i had
her and i had a young son that any time
my mind got off and i was off in my this
monastic sort of sabbatical i was on i
would look to
my newborn or look to my relationship or
say tel convince myself trust trust the
longer you endure this very much like
the australian year yeah i clicked into
it i believe that if you endure this
there's a greater reward at the end
matthew you trust it time's on your side
getting the best seven read some lord
byron
yeah that's great i i don't want to
spoil that whole thing because i want
people
i mean you got a lot out of it
the least of which is not a kick-ass
punchline i mean with the reveal of it
but i mean
in contrast to rhett i think when you
talk when you talk about like counting
the cost and the risk and looking into
the unknown when you're when you're at a
a turning point in your career
i think that that's when it that's the
part that resonates with me because we
have so much like you know yesterday oh
and
i think this you know it may have been
one of your poems in your book or may
have just been something you said so you
know it gets blurry in the audio book if
you're in a poem or not which i i
actually liked i'm like maybe the whole
thing's a poem
but the one when you were you were
talking about
making love to your wife earlier in the
day and then having drinks and it's like
everything after that was like the
dancing was better the drinking was
better the all the other things that you
did with the rest of your day the spices
and the food were better everything the
conversation through them across the
table was all better yeah it does set a
nice stage to have a good session to
begin it yes and you know what yesterday
that happened to me me and christy we we
sorted our mail oh you had more you made
a little morning section
i had morning sex yesterday because she
was leaving to go to north carolina and
you know what i was like
this
and then i and then i was like i'm
taking my my son he's he's got to have
more driving under his belt to get
before he can get his license we're
driving around los angeles we're driving
over the hollywood hills i'm like son
you are driving on sunset the sunset
strip right now
and then we come back around we're going
up it's like let's go up to griffith
griffith observatory and then i get back
home
and i'm hanging out with the family and
i i went for a mountain bike ride i came
home i said i'm going to get in the
bathtub i got in the bathtub and i
looked out the window and i saw the sun
reflecting off the mountains
and i'm like nice this
i feel so secure in this nest this is
beautiful
this is a beautiful thing and a lot of
it had to do with starting off with a
little love making
it it can it can open up the aperture
but it
it can also
trap someone like me
into a sense of comfort
i don't want to i don't want to just put
it out there as a wrong choice
because it it could be a right choice
for somebody i don't know if it is for
me but i do know i have this tendency
to
overvalue security and especially when
i've got so much like that day was and
there was other things i don't if i
walked you through all of it i've been
like damn you've got a perfect day
or i had my perfect day okay so
but i'm at this point where we're having
these conversations and i've you know
i can
i'm fueled off of his
being antsy from a creative standpoint i
benefit from that to pull me out of this
space where i'm like
the risk is scary
the unknown is scary i mean are there
certain things that you have to drop for
to go for what you want and when it gets
to those details and you're having those
tearful conversations
i mean nothing's as scary as
i think when we had nothing and we were
trying to build something right so
that being said i'm still at this point
where
looking into that unknown and saying
okay
what
what's the what am i willing
to give up to go for what is still in my
tank like
like that that you had a passing comment
of
when you were positioning everything
there was a lot of practical steps like
you shut down
a production company i think you said
you shut down a yeah um
a record label i'm like okay mcconaughey
had a regular label of course he did
but and then you shut it down and it's
like when you can't when you feel like
you can do so many
things
it's hard to know
what's what's the right thing to go for
or but if you look really deeply i think
that answers in there for us
and it's just a question of
okay what what are we willing to shut
down yeah to open up
what you know
do we have a buyer's club
a dallas buyers club in our future
i mean how
how much could you see it how much was
it
just
yeah it was hazy
but the but but
the decision
the truth of the decision to say i'm
going to sacrifice
not doing any more of the work that i
haven't been i'm in the i'm on the i'm
in pole position to do
which were the wrong columns
that
that was clear
and that was clear to be in solitude
that was clear to me at 2 a.m
alone
that was a clear clear to me at
3 a.m
with camilla in the dark without any
other noise and so the truth of it was
clear
now the execution becomes the hard part
yeah and then to trust
that
that no matter what i'm taking this now
out into the masses and the weather's
gonna get gnarly trust that to be true
trust that to be believe in that as time
goes by and you start to go ah maybe i
could amend that
you know what i mean
hey let's go but you know you you
how secure are you yesterday
the morning you had
with your family
the morning you had with your wife
my question is
like any good drug
love sex
booze whatever they are
uh fame attention
the problem's not really when we got
when we're on them the problems with why
is it when it becomes hard to live our
life and be secure when we don't have
them
the problem is a week later when you
hadn't hooked up when you haven't had
that morning
why are you a little bit why are you
moving a little bit faster why are you
not why are you why are you
not saying why are you not noticing that
your son's driving on sunset strip
because you're thinking
do i what i got to do here at 11 today
you're thinking ahead you're out of the
moment right yeah so
that's a question that is that i think
is also worth unpacking but to get back
to i think what your last and initial
question your last question was
you've built currency
you've earned currency
you're looking yourself at the base you
guys are going we got we've earned
currency here damn right and we know
we're responsible for it first own that
then go
well i don't want to be foolish with it
but i also don't want to be beholden to
it right so i'm so protective here that
i'm going hey we built this let's just
be so damn happy and so damn impressed
with what we've built
hey let's just fade off and hello better
then maybe we can retire and go play
golf
i don't know it's not what i want to do
at the same time you don't want to take
your currency to vegas and just start
blindly
saying hit me or or
or i fold without looking at your cards
so
first this i would go to this and i
talked about this in the book
process of elimination
before you go to identity before you
affirm about what it is you want to do
you start eliminating what you don't
want to do you were bringing that up i
started eliminating things on my
proverbial monday morning desk my record
company my develop my development things
i was like you got these little
campfires and none of them are just
flaming big you can't they're not enough
flame to really
heat the kitchen not a flame from
valhalla i need to get rid of a few of
the campfires so i can add more time
gasoline wood to these fires that are
most important so then you go what are
the most important ones what are my
non-negotiable things where what's going
with me as i go forward no matter what
the hell i do
what am i going to tend to what gardens
am i tending to i'm taking care of going
forward in my life that are
non-negotiable
yeah for me i go
husbandry and fatherhood my family
that's a non-negotiable whether i
go
run for governor or i go
make a
rock album
that's non-negotiable
yeah so when i look at that and i try to
point those out it helps me go
okay well at least we don't have to
wonder about that one yeah and
as i'm going forward let's just put that
over here in the bag and say if i'm
going wherever i go this is happening
with me
so it's great great to have things
certain things that are black and white
in our life that are not like well i'm
not sure that's debatable no that's not
debatable right yeah i'm not debating
that
it'll help it seems to help it doesn't
answer the question but it does at least
lead you into going i find
having
by having more in front of you and ways
to pathways to get what you want that
you know that could work it it decreases
the amount of options yeah and that's a
good thing yeah and you and it's and i
do think that um
that is the
i'm not gonna say it's easy but it is
the the easy part is making those
identifications right i mean you can you
start thinking about those fires and you
think oh well this this fire is not
really for me this as far as somebody
said that this would be a good idea
right
and you know we do 20 different things
and so you start looking around and like
this one seems strategic because this
person said it was
then the the the hard decision is to is
to
just let that fire or to douse it that
that's that's that's the hard part
how much do we want
i love it man more ideas come on i think
i can take it my biggest asset my
biggest downfall not my big one of my
biggest downfalls would be that i think
i can make anything work i i can be
moved and thinks anything's creative and
anything so yes yeah my biggest
downfall would be the same thing my
biggest upfall would be the same thing
because all of a sudden i'm going to
wait a minute
you know
you get too many things all of a sudden
i got all these campfires here yeah and
i'm inviting more campfires onto my desk
i've questioned like in my life now
going
you don't need new fires you don't need
new ideas
you need to sculpt
what you got yeah
you need to start framing you need to
take that clean up that wood and get
fewer fires larger flames
yeah
that that's good yeah because i can get
i can talk myself into an idea and then
and by the by the afternoon be convinced
that this is this is the best idea
and this yeah here's all the reasons
that this is gonna work but you went you
know i i
we talk about our blood oath a lot you
know it's it's fun but it's it's so
meaningful you know when you wrap things
up and you talk about your top 10
uh list
and you know you read it and you didn't
have to say
that they had been checked off
you know so it's
where what does that mean for your
legacy now
like how do you how do you look at it
because that's kind of where the book
ended but then
well you're not done as i was saying
no i'm not done and some people have
said hey you've accomplished all these
10 goals well no i haven't there's only
one i've accomplished and that was
winning the oscar for best actor the
other nine
my relationship with god my relationship
as a father taking being close to my my
my my parents now that's my mother's the
only one alive those with the
egotistical utility and those
i'm
i'm on the way to succeeding those i'm
i'm but those are i have to work on
those those are some of my
non-negotiables if i look at those i go
you're going to be doing this you're in
process of trying to achieve these goals
till you're you leave this earth
you know it's what i just what i could
what i'm convinced of so
i don't have a new 10 goal sheet
if anything i need to look back at the
original gold sheet and go
how do we better tend these gardens how
do we evolve the tendons
of these gardens of these goals that you
already have
and
not be satisfied i still have an
entrepreneur's spirit of hey but there's
new things world changes let's let's but
i but we also as we know i mean eddie
better says you can change by staying
the same and sticking to sticking to
your modus operandi your original goals
and going no i give that i'm i'm gonna
still take care of that i'm gonna
maintain that i'm gonna make that help
that grow and work on that daily
that changes
you get new ideas new things come in our
lives and we go oh
we get successful we get new
opportunities
i don't know you know there's a great
what would you do with 14 billion
dollars
someone said
take off five zeroes and
do what you do
with fourteen thousand dollars a million
times
right
i don't know where to move the decimal
but i do know what you're saying yeah
you know what i mean and and and there's
and there's there's there's real truth
to that
um
at the same time we don't want to be
hoarders yeah we got success we don't
want to hoard our currency right and say
this is good
i i made it because we know it's not
it's not a summit we're on we know we
didn't get to the top
of anything and i think we also got to
understand that there really is no top
no matter what even if you exceed your
dreams that y'all have right now in 20
years you're not you're not going to be
there in 20 years going we did it and
never you're going to be there in 20
years if you succeed if everything going
what's next yeah right
that's just part of the game yeah yeah
that's good to hear especially from you
you know i i feel like
we've gone through the green lights
workbook and it's not even out yet yeah
well yeah because we want to be mindful
of your time and we could talk to you
forever um we said this is gonna be
selfish and i think you
know uh mission accomplished we got we
got some nights
tell us about the the workbook which
comes out on december 7th i think
yeah this it's a uh the journal so
journal
yeah so i uh
as you know my the book is based off of
37 years of journaling
um right and put out the book and i
noticed that a lot of people
didn't
didn't really journal didn't write
things down but then
would talk to me about oh and they did
they they it really really helped them i
mean so oh yeah it's a jer this is it
um and what you what you what you uh i
got little prompts in here okay so
there's certain things for like for
instance
i'll kick you off you know there you go
tell a love story about your family
all right i'm gonna nudge the the writer
where i was the author of green lights
this is so
you're the author this is your this is
your whoever's got it journal it's it's
your story um i'll be there to guide you
with a couple of hey think about this
think about that um throughout the book
so i'm kind of there with you but
when you write things down
you
you're extending the socratic dialogue
we think we have to try it's credit
dialogue all the times we think things
yeah you know
uh
you two can share things you've got the
the bond etc i have my wife white share
things with another great friends but
man we can
say let's not forget that the first and
foremost and last person that we should
be sharing our thoughts with
and making
obligations with and contracts with
is the
the m and the e
the y o u that's what i mean again by
being self it's a selfish endeavor to be
maybe more selfless to be a better more
truer
yourself to be a a a better person for
more people as well and it starts i
believe with making a contract with
ourselves and you never look back
exploring ourselves you never look at
that and that's what journeys because
we've journaled you know kind of coming
up you never look back and think man i
wish i hadn't recorded that i wish i had
i should have journaled less you always
think man i wish oh there was that there
was that dry spell where i just did like
one thing for a year like you know
and i do think that having that
structure
and those ideas to get you started can
be super helpful yeah very cool
you know you know the other thing i just
say is that we we typically
journaling has gotten that
a bit of a wrong definition that oh you
go to it when you're frustrated confused
and in trouble
okay it's good for that
don't forget to go to it when you are
rolling when you are catching green
lights when you are on time and in line
and on your frequency dissect your
success
dissect the stuff that works in your
relationships
in how you started your day
and how you ended your night in what
worked through the day man because you
will go back i've done it so many times
when i've then gotten into a rut off
frequency lost frustrated confused i've
gone back into my journal and gone what
were you doing back in june man you had
a
that month you were just rolling your
relationships were great your career was
great you you you saw beauty in the
world you were you you were just i was
on on time and i'll go back and i'll see
habits that i had yeah that now that i'm
in a rut i'm going oh you quit doing
that
let's go back and it's helped me
recalibrate and go ah and shift me back
into my lane again
and if you need to install
uh a recorder in your car
you can do that too
i
right
that yeah
whatever it takes that guy's got a cb to
himself
yes it is dj
well matthew man thanks uh so much for
spending the time like i said we're uh
big fans of you big fans of the book and
i just think that uh it totally makes
sense that this
you know the do-it-yourself version is
the next thing with the with the journal
so i um
yeah yeah right that's your story and
you know what now now that um we've
heard from you
uh and had all our questions answered uh
we're gonna go for it and uh we're gonna
we're gonna blame you if it doesn't work
yes
yes please do all right thanks man
thanks thank you call me all right
[Music]
all right we just talked to matthew
mcconaughey
remember that it just happened and uh
you know
it was kind of like uh there's just
sometimes i mean we haven't been like i
said we hadn't been talking to anybody
but besides the two of us but i kind of
just felt like we just kind of hung out
with somebody who he's not going to be
your new best friend knows what you're
thinking no well you know well i've got
something on the side with him
that you that you that you may not know
about but no but i think that the sort
of the rhythm that comes from
uh and again i don't want to make it
think like yeah we've got the same life
experience as matthew mcconaughey as you
as you'll get from that book man
the dude has lived this crazy crazy life
i've never had a dream about some place
and then traveled there twice more than
once in my life i haven't done it at all
so but i do think that just uh yeah that
was a very beneficial conversation for
for the two of us yeah i think um
there's no magic bullet you know it's
not like okay i'm gonna do this because
he said this phrase and everything
clicked into place but i mean
his
the way that he presents his the his
life of stories in the book is very
inspirational it's like
when in doubt go for it
have the experience embrace the
experience versus finding the finding
the excuses to not do it
of course that can't be a blanket
statement
across the board but it's it's
inspirational and a great reminder that
like
going for something and being
up for the
experience of it
harbors so many
rewards that you can't expect and also
chasing who you truly are
and your passions is something that
really resonates and i think a lot of
people you know uh
a lot of our fans may
think oh but yeah it feels like you guys
have lived a life that is you know
leaning into risk and trying new things
and and i know that there is a part of
that and some significant points in our
career that are kind of characterized by
that mentality
but i think that the way that we
perceive ourselves and our critical
analysis of the way that we operate is
that we err on the side of being too
practical yeah and we end up being too
reasonable and we make decisions that
make
too much sense
and i think that there is a a part of us
that is
wants to ask the question well what
would it be like if
fill in the blank with an impractical
question or decision because the fact is
and it's hard for me to see it and say
it that we are in a position where we
could go after things based on the
success that that we have and the
relationship that we have
with uh mythical beasts so it's
um
yeah there's there's still a lot to
think about there
you know and we'll continue to we won't
keep talking about it forever but uh
whose wreck is it well i think that
whoever's it is i mean we know what
we're wrecking i've already wrecked
journally now i can say and if you if
you if you want matthew mcconaughey to
give you thought starters well there's a
journal for that that's coming out
soon green lights journal but yeah
listen to green lights i mean yeah
if you like good stories and i would say
now we both listen to it and and it's an
incredible audiobook because i mean it's
matthew mcconaughey so you know you know
that the way that he's going to
mcconaughey it when he delivers it is
going to be worth your time
i i will say
we also do have the physical copy of the
book and a lot of the things that he
talks about
uh
complete with pictures and
bumper stickers etc a lot of that stuff
is in there so i think it's you know
choose your choose your uh your poison
but both of them are great
and uh
there's a reason that it's it's
reverberated so widely
you know over the past year or so since
it's been out we are leaving on trips
independent of one another uh me and
christy are going on a trip to big sur
and uh i'm going to key west oh man
never been there
never been to that little key little
whatever thing that florida pooped out
at the end of itself it's like it's like
the dribble of pee from the penis that
is florida oh gosh you should have saved
that for your intro that's what we'll be
talking about
next week on your biscuits but um you
know hashtag your biscuits let us know
what you think about this conversation
you probably have some thoughts about
how good is the ego
i don't know exactly if i agree with
them on that but maybe some of it's
semantics but um
get into whatever you want to hashtag
ear biscuits
we'll be here next time on the flip side
of our trips
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]